just a warning we're going to be talking
about hunting and animal trophies in
this episode and if it's not for you you
can scroll back through our feed for
something else
we go out hunting because we really
enjoy hunting I don't think that any
hunter goes out to say I want to help
conservation today but of course we
wouldn't do this unless conservation
works because we need our hunting to be
sustainable
meaning that we can do the same next
year our children will be able to do the
same in the future
now these are the views of Yen's all at
Kirk he works for a Scandinavian hunting
Association Bartz is hunted in Africa
more than 40 times we've been speaking
to him because on this episode we're
looking at trophy hunting
MPS have already voted to ban trophy
hunting Imports in Britain and the bill
is passing through the Lords it was part
of the government's election Manifesto
in 2019 and is a cause taken up by loads
of celebrities including Ricky Gervais
and Joanna Lumley who say hunted animals
need protecting but conservationists in
some African communities say the revenue
they get from trophy hunting is
important to support the work they do
I'm Leah bellesso and this is the Sky
News Daily
later we'll hear from Wildlife
Conservation Professor Amy Dickman as
well as the MP behind the import ban and
more from Hunter yens but first to one
part of Africa Namibia to hear about
what's happening to protect animal
species there on this lens you find what
we call the big mammals which is
elephants you know Lions cheetahs
leopards they live mostly outside of
protected areas which is our national
parks you cannot have these animals
without having forests so these things
go hand in hand so you need to look
after both of them Maxi Pia Louis is a
community leader in Namibia working in
conservation
hi Leah nice to meet you yeah you too
it's looking really sunny there in
Namibia I'm in the middle of a town
called
so which is uh in the north east of
Namibia I have lots of trees where I am
now uh but Namibia is a very contrasting
country so in the Northeast it's a
Savannah and then I'm overlooking the
cavango river which is a Lifeline for
our local people I manage a network of
what we call Civil Society organizations
and we support communities in rural
Namibia that are actually looking after
Wildlife so what we try to do is to
create opportunities and tools for them
to be able to manage those resources
very sustainably on those lands I'm
actually How concerned are you about the
decline in animal populations in Namibia
I was concerned
in the 70s and the 80s when I was
growing up because there was nothing
left and then over the years we have
grown those animals in the 80s for
instance our population in terms of
elephant numbers was around 7 000 and
that now with a lot of the population
censuses that we have been doing over
the past two years that has increased
over 24
000 or more elephants that are moving
around now that is a number that I think
is a country we can be very proud of we
have created a model a conservation
model that actually has increased
wildlife in the areas in Namibia where I
am even to such a level where that we
brought you know species that were close
to extinction back one of them is the
black rhino it's actually flourishing
very well poaching for me that is one of
the areas that I think we need to pay
more attention to we should also be
concentrating more on habitat close
because I sit here I look over these
planes and I can see that a lot of trees
have gone and our Wildlife need those
trees
the World Wildlife Fund estimates around
11 000 rhinos were poached in Africa
between 2008 and 2021 the black rhino
remains on the critically endangered
animals list but in Namibia and South
Africa where trophy hunting is regulated
numbers have been increasing in recent
years so Maxie how important would you
say trophy hunting is for the
communities you work with it's a pillar
in terms of income that is generated for
GDP it's the third largest in terms of
making that contribution those funds
coming in they contribute quite heavily
to some of the work that we're doing to
try and conserve wildlife in those areas
but also making sure there is motivation
for people to manage those resources
do you personally think of hunting
groups trophy handing is not something
that is very foreign to Africans in
other nations and especially indigenous
communities that is something that has
always been done in our communities
where it became very negative for me
it's when it was overused but now we are
using it very much sustainably and it's
yielding really good profits and it's a
good model for us
the amount of Revenue communities
working in conservation get from hunting
groups isn't clear because we're told it
varies but people will pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a license to
hunt the critically endangered black
rhino
the hunter we heard from earlier Yen's
urlich cook doesn't have that kind of
money but he's been to Africa many times
I have a set of of Moosh horns from
Kamchatka because they are impressive I
actually think they look nice I had a
heck of a trip to Kamchatka in in 2014
during the winter time it was just a
great experience and
it was a souvenir to bring back from
that just as all the photos I took and
everything but then on the other hand
I've been to Africa maybe 40 plus times
hunting and I think I have three or four
so-called hunting trophies from Africa
out of hundreds and hundreds of hunts
that I've participated in to me
it's all just hunting it's all just
recreational hunting and and we we do
basically exactly the same when we hunt
here in Europe as when we hunt in Africa
there's always a land user somewhere who
is interested in in Wildlife Management
which is a big part of this as always a
land use who's interested in some income
there's always some local job
opportunities arising from this the meat
is always utilized all these things are
exactly the same no one shot is perfect
it could leave an animal wounded so
there's those issues around it that are
problematic I suppose also wounding an
animal is a concern with all hunting
wounding an animal is a concern when we
call Red Deer in the Scottish Highlands
always and of course that's something
that Hunters need to educate themselves
for and they do yes you've been hunting
since you were 15. have you ever felt a
sense of guilt and is it about
conservational for you I think for most
hunters myself included we go out
hunting because we really enjoy hunting
I don't think that any hunter goes out
to say I want to help conservation today
but of course we wouldn't do this unless
this conservation works because we need
our hunting to be sustainable
meaning that we can do the same next
year our children will be able to do the
same in the future and so on and if it's
not sustainable
there's no future for hunting because we
need strong populations in strong
natural habitat and that's why there's
no hunting without conservation it's
simply not going to work you do care
about conservation that's clear why not
just give the money that you have for
those hunts directly to conservation
Charities because we like to hunt as I
say we are recreational Hunters because
we enjoy participating in that local
Wildlife Management in that manner it's
a mental challenges a physical challenge
we get to see nature in all kinds of
different ways that non-hunters don't so
we are motivated by our passion for the
hunt we get this question a lot why
don't you just give the money is for the
same reason that everybody else doesn't
give a lot of money why don't the photo
Safari tourists just donate all the
money that a photo Safari costs and
watch the wildlife on Discovery Channel
Channel they would spare the atmosphere
for a lot of jet fuel going back and
forth people pursue their passion so
there is nothing is there that would
persuade you to put the guns down and
stop hunting one thing would if I
learned that some sort of hunting were
damaging for for the Wildlife and
damaging for the populations and the
natural habitat I would Advocate to stop
that kind of hunting
immediately we do not want to damage the
foundation of our future passion at any
cost there are some people yens that
will say actually what you do is
distasteful they see those pictures of
someone standing over a lion or a black
rhino that's been shot and those
pictures are plastered on newspapers or
online and that's problematic what would
you say to those people I would say that
I do understand how people can see these
pictures as problematic typically what I
experience is that
they do not really know the whole story
behind this it's very counter-intuitive
to understand that hunting is beneficial
for say the black rhino population
because the black rhino is listed as
critically endangered but in fact the
only two countries in the world that has
a rising population of black rhino is
Namibia and South Africa doesn't there
need to be a concerted effort from
Hunters not to promote these pictures
that look striking and that are very
upsetting to people who love animals
that would definitely be very very
helpful to practical conservation
efforts all over the world if we in The
Hunting Community were able to educate
our own a little bit better
not to confuse everything with these
very provocative images
so would you say then to the hunting
Community stop posting these images
where it goes wrong is that you see this
picture of This heavyweight guy smiling
grinning behind the deadline but you do
not see the old background story
up to 90 percent of people according to
many opinion polls say that they no
longer want to have hunting trophies so
body parts from endangered species
imported into this country just for some
sort of sick display Henry Smith is the
conservative MP behind the bill to ban
trophy hunting Imports in Britain
I think we've moved on perhaps from the
era of big game hunting uh that might
have been popular 100 to 100 years ago
and this is an issue that people rightly
care about because these are endangered
species uh which if we don't act more
now we could see the end of some iconic
animals like elephant or polar bears
I've spoken to African Community leaders
who claim their voices aren't being
heard and they say some of the revenue
from trophy huntings used for
conservation jobs security to stop
poaching and without it animal
populations could be at risk we're not
telling countries in Africa how to run
their conservation efforts I might have
a personal view on theirs but that's not
what this bill does this also extends to
all endangered species as listed
internationally so that also includes
polar bears so the idea that we're
telling for example the Canadians how to
run their conservation that's also not
what we're doing this is a bill saying
we choose not to import the body parts
of endangered species into this country
I'd say there's very little evidence to
suggest that fees from hunting trophies
go back into African communities this is
a neocolonial sport this was introduced
by Europeans when they colonized Africa
a couple of hundred years ago if an
animal is endangered and on the brink of
Extinction then it seems very strange to
me that you would kill that animal to
conserve that animal there is big money
in the trophy hunting industry Safari
Club International these are Lobby
groups that are interested in preserving
the trophy hunting industry this really
is something that I think we should
consign to the history books often it's
not a clean kill often it takes many
hours or even a day for an animal to to
die in agony
when Henry Smith put forward his private
members Bill last year to stop the body
parts of endangered animals being
brought into Britain not everyone agreed
with it a Global Environmental Network
made up of governments and Civil Society
organizations published an open letter
warning against a blanket ban and it was
signed by scientists conservationists
and African Community Leaders with the
international Union for conservation of
nature saying it risked reversing
conservation gains and undermining the
livelihoods of rural communities in
parts of Africa trophy hunting really
isn't a significant threat to any
species actually and in this debate it's
one of the most frustrating things
that's come out to my mind is this real
misconception of the things that we see
most on social media the things that
look the worst in the papers that people
get the most angry and irate about
sitting as they read over their morning
coffee are not necessarily reflective of
the major conservation threats that we
see in the field Professor Amy Dickman
heads up the wildlife conservation
research units at the University of
Oxford she's also joint CEO of lion
Landscapes conservation and research
organization in Africa
the things really driving biodiversity
decline are things like habitat loss
primarily and also issues like poaching
for example
and these major factors are really
driving species to Extinction and it was
brought to lots of people's attention
wasn't it back in 2015 and with that
photo that was on the front pages of
lots of newspapers of Cecil the lion and
he had been killed by this American
dentist in Zimbabwe and I think what was
more shocking perhaps was that it was
perfectly legal in Zimbabwe I was quite
surprised how many people didn't realize
that trophy hunting is legal and still
continues extensively including here in
the UK it has major impacts obviously on
the hunted Lions it can have negative
impacts on populations of lions
including around places like wangi where
at that time the quotas were too high
what is threatening lions are things
like the loss of prey killing lines and
things like snares human Wildlife
conflict and a primary thing to all
Wildlife is the maintenance of habitats
and trophy hunting as horrible as it can
look can actually help provide Revenue
provide incentives for governments for
other landowners to maintain Wild
habitats and tolerate dangerous species
like lions so there's a real risk in
actually reacting to images horrible
images of that you know dentists posing
with the dead body of Cecil and saying
we must ban it because what you're very
likely to have then is that those areas
get less economically valuable people
convert them maybe to Farmland to crop
land to livestock keeping and then
people will snare Lions will poison them
no one will see those pictures on the
front of the daily mail or the evening
standard or whatever but we will see
them in the field and those deaths are
horrifying awful and far worse in terms
of conservation and Welfare actually
than most trophy hunting deaths are I
don't feel that we should be having
complex difficult decisions made by what
a celebrity thinks you know during the
covid lockdowns when we all had those
daily briefings I never saw Judi Dench
your wreckage a vase up there and people
saying what do you think we should do at
the daily briefings they always talked
to the people who had a really good
understanding of the complexities of the
topic and conservation deserves no less
than that let's talk about Wildlife
Conservation then what does it involve
and how much money is needed you know to
make a difference in African communities
significant amounts of funding so the
Lions for example there's at least a
billion dollars a year probably more
like two or three billion dollars a year
required for Effective line conservation
just in the protective areas the
national parks the game reserves where
they occur and at the moment we've got a
shortfall of at least 600 million
probably close to one one and a half
maybe two billion dollars a shortfall of
that which means that most protected
areas are not able to be well managed
people don't realize that actually photo
tourism trophy hunting donor Aid and
state aid all combined together are
still nowhere near sufficient for
Effective conservation what evidence do
you have or you know about that trophy
hunting is actually helping conservation
I hate the idea of trophy hunting you
know I love animals my whole career has
been about reducing Wildlife killing but
from the realities of being on the
ground when you fly over these areas
when you see the vast amounts of
wildlife habitat that are protected
under trophy hunting areas it really
reinforces the scale that most people
aren't able to see when the engagement
is just from say a Twitter debate one of
the analysis did show that around the
fifth more land was actually protected
under trophy hunting areas than under
national parks so given that habitat
loss is the main threat to Wildlife we
should really be acting very very
carefully before we undermine a business
model for land that actually protects
more land more wildlife habitats than
National Parks do if the UK doesn't like
trophy hunting then what the UK should
do is Ban it domestically and I think
many people don't realize that we export
tens of thousands of trophies
in the village land that I've worked on
in southern Tanzania the level of lion
killing there was between 50 and 100
times higher than would be permitted in
a trophy hunting area and horrible
killings poisoning snarings spearings
pregnant females young cubs you would
have the bycatch of critically
endangered vultures you know we would go
along and find six dead lions and a
mound of critically endangered vultures
all killed from one poisoning event so I
think our focus should be not just
looking at one cause of death like
trophy hunting we should really be
cognizant of the fact that if we take
that away with no better alternative in
place then you're going to end up with
more of those kinds of killings but what
do you think would be
alternatives to trophy hunting if all
the groups who just who hate trophy
hunting are campaign against it if they
funded the maintenance of these areas
then we wouldn't be having to have this
discussion but that's not happening you
know in Tanzania in four years after the
U.S import bans we saw that half of
Tanzania hunting blocks went vacant and
it was seeing more illegal Wildlife use
in those places we're seeing more
habitat loss all these threats are
coming because there is no better
alternative stepping it so what we are
working hard on is that other partners
is trying to think of new conservation
models things like biodiversity credits
could be one way for instance where the
Richer countries actually pay the poorer
countries who tend to have more of the
biodiversity for maintaining that
biodiversity but offsetting the costs
that are imposed on local people and I
think we need to develop those new more
resilient
um more Equitable conservation models
first and then if people decide that
those are out competing things like
trophy hunting will be in a much
stronger position to actually have the
removal of trophy hunting if that's
what's desired but in a place that
doesn't undermine conservation rights
and Animal Welfare Maxi Pier Louis is
concerned import bands by Western
countries could indirectly harm
conservation I can see that certain
decisions are going to take us
50 years back if we are not careful in
the way we do things and I'm just very
worried that by the time we open up our
eyes we might not even have one single
elephant a lion a leopard left and that
will be the status day of Our Lives that
we try to have a goal of saving
something but in actual fact we killed
it off
my thanks to our guests and you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Leah bellesso this episode was produced
by Annie Joyce our editors Philly
Beaumont